بعد تطمينه بيض افتتحت الاسم الامريكيه
على تراجع بسيط في اول جلسه لها بعد
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ثم عادت الى
تصحيح وضعها تدريجيا فيما هوى سهم البنك
فرست الامريكيه عند الافتتاح بنحو 67
بالمئه وتراجع ايضا مؤشر الاسهم الامريكيه
في مطلع افتتاح
[موسيقى]
الاداره بالتحرك سريعا لاحتواء تداعيات
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي بامكان المودعين
الوصول الى اموالهم بدون عوائق المستثمرون
الذين يخاطرون بودائع الامريكيين ستتم
محاسبتهم ولن تكون هناك حمايه لاصحاب
قرارات المخاطر التي ادت لهذه الازمه ولن
نسمح بتكرار اخفاقات البنوك وسنعمل على
حمايه الشركات الناشئه اريد التاكيد على
ان دافعي الضرائب لم يتحملوا اي خسائر
بسبب ازمه البنوك
سؤال الساعه لماذا انهار بنك سيليكون فالي
الذي طالما حاضيه بثقه عملائه القصه قبل
نحو اسبوع اعلن البنك بيع عدد من الاوراق
الماليه بسعر يؤدي للخساره ما خلق حاله من
الفزع بين شركه اداره رؤوس الاموال التي
نصحت الشركات بسحب اموالها فورا العديد من
شركات التكنولوجيا على مدى عقود استخدمت
هذا البنك للاحتفاظ بالنقض ما ادى الى
تدفق الودائع لكن مع استثمار البنك جزءا
كبيرا من الودائع بدات الازمه الماليه
تحدث ليبدا العد التنازلي للبنك في فقدان
قيمه السندات خصوصا بعد ان بدا الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي رفع اسعار الفائده بسرعه
لمكافحه او مواجهه التضخم
زادت حينما قرر العملاء سحب مبالغ من
ودائعهم ما اجبر البنك على بيع بعض
السندات بخسائر لتوفير السيول اللازمه في
الثامن من مارس بدا العد التنازلي عندما
اعلن البنك عن زياده راس المال بقيمه ما
يقرب من 2 مليار دولار لينتهي الامر بعد
يومين بانهيار البنك تماما الذي بلغ راس
ماله 200 مليار دولار وهو ما يمثل اكبر
فشل المصرفي في الولايات المتحده منذ
الازمه الماليه العالميه في 2008
هناك تطورات اخيره تهم بعض البنوك التي
اراقبها بعنايه شديده وعندما تتعرض البنوك
لخسائر ماليه يجب ان يكون ذلك مصدر قلق
سيليكون بالي مجله نظام التامين الفيدرالي
يغطي ودائع تصل الى 250 الف دولار ويحمي
جميع الاموال النقديه لمعظم الافراد في
حساب المصرفي حجم المدخرات زاد من 44
مليار دولار نهايه 2017 الى 189 مليار
دولار في نهايه 2021
نمو القروض من 23 مليارا الى 66 مليار
دولار وجود ودائع اكبر بكثير من القروض
استثمار 128 مليار دولار نهايه 2021
معظمها في سندات الرهن العقاري وسندات
الخزانه الانهي ار له تداعيات عالميه
بينها سوق العملات المشفره وتاثير سلبي
على الشركات التقنيه او الناشئه صحيفه
الجارديان العديد من الشركات والافراد قد
يخسرون اكثر من نصف ودائعهم